[MUSIC PLAYING]
RICK VISCOMI: Hello, world.
Welcome to Google
Developers Live.
My name is Rick Viscomi, and I'm
going to be presenting on
waterfall antipatterns.
So to kick it off, waterfall
antipatterns has to do with
web performance.
And measuring web performance
is kind of a tricky subject,
because it comes in two parts.
Number one is getting your
company to care about web
performance.
And I think we're in the--
we're lucky, right now,
because companies are
recognizing that web performance
is directly
related to all the metrics that
they care about, like
returning visitors, ad
conversions, things like this.
When a company decides to care
about web performance, they
ask their engineers to fire
up a tool and measure the
performance, so they know
how fast they are.
And we're lucky to have a
tool called WebPagetest.
And this tool was created by
Patrick Meenan at AOL, and he
now works at Google.
So this is a tool that would
synthetically measure the
performance of a website.
And here in red, I've
highlighted some areas that
you should focus on before you
run your test, to make sure
that you have all the
information needed to get an
informed decision about how
your performance is.
So the first thing I'll point
out is that the number of
tests to run is set to nine.
You might notice on the left
it says, up to 10.
But we've chosen an odd number
here, and I'll show
you why in a second.
Also, right below that, Repeat
View is set to both first view
and repeat view.
And this is so that we can hit
the page once with a clear
cache, and then hit it again
just to see how well we are
caching our resources.
And up and to the right, we
see that the Video tab is
highlighted.
Capturing video is important
so that we can get what's
known as perceived performance
metrics.
Capturing a video is basically
taking snapshots every tenth
of a second of the web page.
And using these snapshots, we
could see just like a live
playback of how the
page is loading.
And this could tell us the
sequencing of where things are
loading in on the page, and how
quickly that compares to
other websites and other test
runs of the same page.
So one thing to note is that I
mentioned that WebPagetest is
a synthetic tool.
There are two categories of
performance monitoring and
measurement, and that's
RUM, Real User
Monitoring, and synthetic.
Real user monitoring measures
the performance experience of
the actual users
of a web page.
There's lots of variability
here.
Users are coming from all
around the world.
Many different browsers, many
different connection speeds.
And they basically count for
many, if not all of the edge
cases of how many people could
be hitting your site, and
under what conditions.
Synthetic testing is
almost like clean
room laboratory testing.
As you can see, WebPagetest lets
you control almost all
the variables, the connection
speed, the
location, the browser.
And there's very little
variation between the tests,
if you want it to be so.
So they sort of answer two
different questions.
With RUM, it's answering the
question, how fast is my page?
And for synthetic, it's
answering the question, how
can I make my page faster?
And so today, we're going to
focus on synthetic, and how we
can use WebPagetest, and
specifically, waterfall chart
to make our pages faster.
So I mentioned that nine runs
is better than 10 runs.
And I'll explain that with a
little bit of mathematics.
So when you have nine runs,
it's an odd number.
And so when you take the median
of nine runs, you're
left with the fifth
one in the series.
As opposed to 10 runs, you're
left with five and six in the
middle, and you're left with
some sort of decision about
which one to take.
So when you have nine runs,
you're always going to have
one test run to pick, and
there's no ambiguity.
So that's just a demonstration
of nine versus 10, and nine is
recommended.
So moving on, this is the
waterfall that you'll actually
see when you run a test.
And it's shrunken down here, to
give us a high level view
of what's going on.
When we run our test, and we see
this waterfall, at first
we're sort of wondering,
what is going on here?
We're wondering, what are
we supposed to look for?
You might notice, oh, at the
top of the page, it says it
ran in 15 seconds.
That's great.
We have a number.
But what does that number
actually mean, and what can we
derive from that 15 seconds?
The truth is that 15 seconds
is one particular load time
for this one particular test.
It's not representative
of all your users.
That's the difference between
RUM and synthetic.
And the other thing to note is
that this specific test felt
like 15 seconds, but when I
loaded on my own, in my own
browser, it feels like
three seconds.
So that difference has to
do with this clean room
laboratory testing environment
on WebPagetest.
It clears all the caches, and
in your own private browser,
it contains a lot of information
about your
previous history.
So something to note here
is that time is not very
important, which might
sound strange.
But time is not very important,
because it's not
representative of
all your users.
Time is important when you
compare it against other
WebPagetest results.
Also, timing could also be
thrown off by anomalies over
the network.
And this is why we run nine
tests, so that you can choose
a median run that will sort of
smooth over the differences.
So when we look at a waterfall
from this high level, one
technique that I've learned to
use is by looking at something
called waterfall slope.
And slope is the rate at
which requests are
being made over time.
So we have the requests running
down the page from top
to bottom, and from left to
right is the time axis,
starting at 0 in the top left.
And so what we want to see
is a vertical line
going straight down.
Think of this like Niagara
Falls, just flowing straight
down, quickly.
So that means that we're doing
more in less time.
We are able to get more requests
out in a shorter
amount of time.
These horizontal lines, like
the one second to last, is
pretty bad.
That means that we're doing
less in more time.
This is an indicator that we
could be more efficiently
using our bandwidth to get more
content over the network.
So waterfall slope isn't really
something that's talked
about a lot.
And what I really like about
slope is that it's something
that could be quantified.
You could measure the slope of
a waterfall, and compare it
against other pages.
So this is one way to
quantitatively compare
waterfalls, other than the
standard way of just
qualitatively looking at them
side by side and wondering
what's different.
So these horizontal lines can
be made up of all of these
little antipatterns.
And these arrows are showing
you each antipattern.
And right now, it looks
like a mess.
They're sort of scattered
around.
And they are, there's
a lot going on here.
And hopefully, at the end of
this talk, you'll be able to
spot them and pick them out.
So this is the high level
view of a waterfall.
Let's dig down and look at
the anatomy of a request.
And starting all the way at the
left, we see that there's
a little padlock icon.
And this is to show us that
this is a secure request.
Not all requests are secure.
And it usually will go along
with this purple
bar towards the right.
So if you see a padlock, that's
indicating that the
request was made over SSL.
Next is the number two.
This is to indicate that this
was the second request to
occur, followed by a center
truncated domain name and
resource name.
So we see that the domain here
is fb static, and the
resources is a bunch of numbers
and letters .css.
This is helpful, just at a
glance, to see what type of
request this is, and for
what resource it is.
The next thing is a solid black
line, followed by some
gray lines.
And the spacing between that
solid black line and the first
colored bar is what's known
as the start offset.
This is the amount of time that
has passed since the page
has started to load to the
time that the request was
first made.
And we come now to the DNS
lookup, that teal bar, which
is basically the resolution
of example.com to its
machine-readable IP address.
DNS lookup looks short
and innocent here.
But it could actually trip you
up, in that if example.com is
trying to be resolved to its
IP, there could be a server
that doesn't know
the IP address.
And that server has to
ask another server
later on in the chain.
And so this lookup chain can
be unpredictably long.
And so a best practice is to
always minimize the number of
unique domains that you use,
to minimize this penalty of
DNS lookup.
Although it looks short
and fast here, that's
not always the case.
Moving on to initial
connection, this
is the orange bar.
And initial connection
is the TCP setup.
And after you've established
your connection, after you've
established the address of the
server, the client or the
browser needs to establish
a connection.
And this also looks short and
fast, but it might not always
be the case.
There's a thing called
TCP slow start.
So not every connection
will be as fast.
And this also is incurred
every time that a new
connection needs to be opened.
There's a technique that we'll
see later to reuse
connections.
Next is SSL negotiation.
Again, this goes hand in hand
with that padlock icon.
And SSL negotiation is
ensuring that you can
communicate securely
with the server.
So just a back step, we've
established the address of the
server, we've made a connection
to that server, and
now client and server are
going to come up with an
agreement about a secure channel
of communication.
And all of this is happening
before the server has even
done anything with what we're
trying to request.
None of this so far has had
anything to do with CSS.
And so that's what TTFB, or
Time To First Byte, does.
So the server finally receives
those request headers for the
CSS resource, and it does some
back end processing to get
that ready for delivery.
And the width of this green
bar is showing you the
duration of time that
the server takes to
process this request.
And as with every bar that we're
going to see here, it
should be as small
as possible.
Moving on, this blue content
download bar is
showing us the time.
The leftmost line on this blue
chart, this blue bar, is
showing you the time that the
server has started to send
some information back
to the browser.
And the width is time it
takes to load all of
the information back.
And of course, we want this to
be as small as possible.
So we could try to minimize the
size of the CSS resource,
to ensure that it's sent more
quickly, or we could have our
user on a faster network, so you
can send more information
in less time.
We can't control that.
But what we can control is
the size of the resource.
The last thing here is the
number 1,247 ms. This is
basically one and a
quarter second to
process the entire request.
And that's the leftmost edge
of the teal bar to the
rightmost edge of
that blue bar.
Some other things of importance
to note is that
some colors might be missing.
You're not always loading
things over SSL.
You're not always setting
up that TCP connection.
And the other thing is that it's
not always contiguous.
Here, you see all colors
next to each other.
But you might see DNS lookup
and initial connection
separated from time to first
byte and content download.
It looks a little strange
at first.
You might wonder if
something broke.
It's totally OK.
It's actually a good thing.
This means that you're
pre-fetching, or
pre-connecting to the server.
This is more typical in newer
browsers, and it's something
that you can control using HTML
meta tags in the head.
OK, so for every request,
there is a response.
And sometimes, those responses
are to say that what you
wanted was not actually in
the location at which you
requested it.
And in this example,
we're loading
facebook.com over HTTP.
And facebook.com has
a 302 redirect.
302 is found.
Found is basically saying,
it moved temporarily.
You can continue to use
this resource URI.
And after facebook.com
redirects to https
facebook.com, it does another
TCP connection.
It does SSL negotiation now,
because we're on a secure
request, and then there's some
time to first byte back end
processing time.
And finally, after one and a
half seconds, it does a 301
Moved Permanently redirect to
https://www.facebook.com.
I'm not trying to pick
on Facebook.
This is just a really good
example of redirects, and the
penalty it can incur.
So we see that, after all is
said and done, the start
offset for the third request
is about two seconds.
So is Facebook wrong to do
this type of redirect?
No.
This is probably a deliberate
move to funnel
people to https www.
And in fact, this screen shot
was taken a few months ago,
and they've since improved it so
that request one does a 301
directly to request three,
which is very good.
And so in that case, instead
of loading at two seconds,
request three, in theory, should
load at half a second,
which is a great improvement.
And that 301 Moved Permanently,
just as a side
note, is just saying that you
should cache this redirect,
because you should not
make this request
again in the future.
So as long as that's in cache,
hitting facebook.com over http
should redirect on the client
side to https www.
And that's an efficiency
on the client side.
Moving on.
Some other types of responses
have to do
with caching, again.
In this case, we're looking
at Not Modified.
And this is made on what's
known as the
Conditional GET request.
This happens when there's some
information that the client
knows about the resource, but it
doesn't know if it's still
fresh, or if it should
continue to
use it from the cache.
And so this is typically done
when the resource is missing,
and expires, or a cache-control
max-age header.
And these headers tell the
client to keep the resource in
cache for a certain
amount of time.
And when the client lacks
this information, it
has to ask the server.
And so we see in the chart to
the left the time to first
byte, but no blue content
download.
So there is no content download
because the 304
response is telling the client
to continue to use
what it has in cache.
Caching is a great thing.
It should continue to be used.
But so why could this be
a bad antipattern?
So if the client has it in
cache, it should continue to
use it in cache, and it should
know how long it's fresh.
When it doesn't have that
information, it
has to ask the server.
And so when it's all said and
done, these green lines add
up, and it comes out to
be about 10 seconds.
So instead of instantly using
what it has in cache, it has
to wait another 10 seconds.
And there's a lot
going on here.
There are many, many requests
having to be made.
So what we can do in this second
bullet point is to say
that we should cache static
content with a long TTL, or
Time To Live.
But we could do that with a
cache-control max-age header.
And this pretty big number.
31,536, is the number of
seconds in a year.
So one year is the longest
time to indicate that a
resource should be cached
indefinitely.
In theory, you could say, I want
this to be cached for 10
years, or something.
But that actually violates
the written spec.
So when cache-control is used
in conjunction with
last-modified, we have two
bits of information.
We know the last time that this
resource was touched, and
that happens to be
today's date.
And we know that it should
continue to be served from
cache for the next year.
And some people sort of get
nervous when they see this
type of information being sent
to the client, because they
might think, well, if it's going
to be cached for a year,
what if I want to make
a change tomorrow?
And how will I ensure that they
don't just have the old,
outdated information?
This could be serious, if you're
serving, like making a
security patch.
So there's a technique known
as cache-busting.
And there are a couple
ways to do it.
One is to append a query string
parameter at the end of
the resource.
And the other suggested way
here is to just change the
file name itself.
In this example, instead of
serving style.css, we have
style underscore and then
some date stamp.
And we can change that date
stamp to whatever we want.
Most commonly, it's the date
that the file was modified.
And so tomorrow, we might
set this to 2013 06 14.
And so what happens when
there is a new
resource being requested?
It totally ignores
what's in cache.
So if the cache is full, it
might see this new resource
being come in, and then eject
the old one, thus making room
for this new resource.
So caching is very important.
It's said, sometimes, that the
fastest request is the one you
never even have to make
in the first place.
So by leveraging caching, and
doing so effectively, you're
tremendously speeding up the
client-side experience on
subsequent repeat views.
Caching does not help them so
much when they're hitting your
website for the first time.
So the other type of response
is an error.
And I think we're all familiar
with what a 404 Not Found
error message is.
So I won't spend a
lot of time here.
But this waterfall gives us an
opportunity to sort of think
about what might have
gone wrong here.
It's interesting, 45, 46, and
47, are for resources named
menu two, three, and four, and
48 through 50 are for an
undefined resource.
So we might wonder what
happened here.
And I laugh, because in my
mind, when I saw this
waterfall, I thought maybe
they were in some type of
JavaScript loop, and they ran
outside the edge of their
array, and they had no more
resources to fetch.
So it's sort of funny to see it
like this, but it is a bad
pattern, because it's holding
up everything after it.
We can see the delay
that this incurs.
It takes half a second
each, with
maybe a second in between.
These gray lines, these gray
vertical lines, are probably
one second indicators.
And so requests 51 and below
are being held up by these
404-ing responses.
So it's important to spot
these red lines.
That's why they stand out so
much in your waterfall.
And take care of that as
soon as you could.
The other type of response or
message you might see in a
waterfall is for request
cancelled.
And this is kind of a strange
thing, because it says it
takes 0 milliseconds.
And we're trained to think that
the smaller the duration
the better, but 0 is actually
not all that good.
This is a strange waterfall.
This was actually created on
the fly using the waterfall
customization feature
of WebPagetest.
And so note that the request
numbers are out of
order on the left.
And so it goes from 51, 2 and
3, to 84, 86, and 87.
And request 51 was made
at about three
and a quarter seconds.
And looking closely, request 84
happens a couple of seconds
later for the same
exact resource.
It's kind of hard to tell, but
these are all three different
image formats.
So the gif image was requested
at 51, and again on 84.
And this is the same resource,
being requested twice.
And the thing that's strange,
you might look at your code
and try to assure yourself,
well, I'm
only calling it once.
Why is it showing up twice
in the waterfall?
So the reason why is that it's
being canceled the first time.
It attempted to load this
resource at an earlier time,
and it failed for some reason,
and then it tried again, this
time successfully, later on.
And the second half of the
slide is showing you the
reason why this happens.
And it occurs because of
something known as the
lookahead pre-parser, where it
tries to look ahead in your
code, and guess what you're
going to need next.
And it will try to load that as
early as possible for it,
which is a great feature.
Although, there are some things
you could do in your
code to trip it up and cause
it to not work so well.
And these lines in red are
showing you where it could get
tripped up.
So the first line is the meta
tag for the http-equivalent of
the character set.
And character set is important
because it tells the rendering
document how to interpret the
data that's being presented.
A common character set,
for example, is UTF-8.
The next meta tag is the
X-UA compatible.
This is to tell the browser
to render in a
different user agent.
So for example, you might
want IE9 to behave
like IE8, and so on.
Next is the base tag.
I hadn't known about the
base tag previously.
I've never used it.
So in looking it up,
I was surprised to
find what it does.
And the base tag pretty much
supplants the host on which
relative paths are
being served.
So if you're on example.com,
and you want to load a
resource slash example.php,
base will allow you to
supplant that host name
with example2.com.
So you could maintain relative
paths, but only change the
code in one place.
And base sort of reminds me
of the with statement in
JavaScript, if anybody's
familiar.
The with statement lets you
supplant the context of a
JavaScript object.
And there's a saying that
the with statement
is considered harmful.
And I'll extend that
to the base tag.
The base tag is considered
harmful, for the reason that
it can cause these
cancel requests.
It's not used too often, but
when it is, improperly, it can
slow down your website.
So the reason why these things
are contributing to this
antipattern is because when
they're out of order, the
rendering agent will make
false assumptions.
So, for example, taking
character set.
If the character set is defined
later on in the
document, for example, the
bottom of your HTML head, it
will have to make an assumption
as it processes the
document that it's a particular
character set.
It might not agree with what
you set it to be later.
So it'll start making requests
under a certain assumption of
character set.
And as soon as it comes across
this meta tag saying that it's
something else entirely, it
will have to cancel, and
basically throw out those
previous requests.
And then there is a note at
the bottom that this is
Internet Explorer specific.
I've seen this especially in
Internet Explorer 7, which
hopefully we're not testing
too much in.
But if we are, this is why you
might see this pattern.
And I will share these slides,
and I encourage you
to click this link.
It has a great article on the
Microsoft blog about all of
this, and why this happens.
Moving on now to navigation
timing.
When you are using a more modern
browser, you might see
some extra colors in your
waterfall chart.
Almost all browsers that I
know of will have this
vertical green and
dark blue line.
The green line is Start Render,
the blue line is
Document Complete.
But we also have this purple,
and light blue bars.
And unlike the green lines,
these actually have a width
associated with them.
And so starting from left to
right, this purple bar,
domContentLoaded, is pretty
much equivalent to
document.ready.
So if you're familiar with
jQuery, you might have a ready
event handler.
So this will pretty much be
fired whenever the document is
ready to be--
or the document object model
is done being processed.
And the width of this line is
representative of the amount
of time you're spending in
that event handler in
JavaScript.
And the common theme today is
everything should be as narrow
as possible.
So a bar that is about 1.6
seconds wide is pretty bad.
And keeping in mind that the
browser is single threaded,
your JavaScript is going to be
taking up time that the user
could be interacting
with the page.
So that's one reason.
The other reason is that this
purple bar comes, in this
case, immediately before
the green line.
The green line is Start
Render, or the first
paint of the page.
And first paint means this is
the time that something was
finally displayed
on the screen.
So the green line occurs at
about 2.8 seconds here.
So that literally means the user
had a blank white page up
until this point, when something
was displayed.
And so thinking about these two
events next to each other,
we want to display something
to the page as soon as
possible, and then we could
do our script processing.
So by having purple before
green, that's further delaying
this Start Render event.
And moving on to this light
blue loadEvent, this is
equivalent to the onload event
handler in your JavaScript.
This is more commonly a lot
shorter than the purple.
Onload event handling is useful
if you want to preload
some resources later on the
page below the fold, or
triggering other types of
nonessential things, maybe
telling an ad to kick in, or
sending back some data to a
web performance beacon.
Finally, Document Complete is
roughly equivalent to the
loadEventStart.
And typically this occurs after
the load event handler.
But just keep in mind that it's
the loadEventStart is the
associated event here.
So using all these terminologies
of timing
events, we might sort of get
confused about what they mean
and how they relate
to each other.
So this is the chart made by
the working group of the
navigation timing API.
And this shows us the ordering
of events in this API.
And this is all available to
you in newer browsers.
But when I saw this, I
kind of got a little
lost in all the details.
So one thing that I found
helpful was to just mute out
everything that's not directly
relevant to WebPagetest.
And we're left with
all of this.
But even still, I wasn't really
satisfied, so I did
some color coding, and we
arrived at this chart, which I
found to be really helpful.
The colors correspond to the
previous slide, and we can see
directly how these colorings
are related back to the
navigation timing API.
domContentLoaded is occupied
with this entire purple bar.
That light blue bar is occupied
in that entire
loadEvent handler.
And then we're left with these
green and blue lines.
So working from right to left,
this blue line is immediately
after loadEventStart.
But this green line is sort of
floating around in the middle
of the processing bar.
And green, first paint, is
not directly tied to any
performance event.
We can't really qualitatively
measure the time of the first
paint just by looking
at the data.
It has more to do with the
visuals on the page.
And so this is an example of
one perceived performance
metric, or a metric in which
the user is the one
experiencing this type of event,
rather than an event
being fired off in an amount
of milliseconds.
This is sort of the feeling
that a user gets when
something happens.
And so that's why it's floating
around in the middle.
OK, so moving on to some other
patterns of-- instead of
requests and their responses as
one unit, now we're going
to look at requests, how they
interact with each other, and
could potentially negatively
affect performance.
So this is an antipattern
known as request
serialization, also known as
the stair step pattern.
And for reference, I included
this red slope line to left,
just to show you the direction
that we're going.
It's down and to the
right, and it's at
an OK type of slope.
It's not totally vertical, it's
not totally horizontal.
But the fact that it extends
outward in that manner is an
indicator that this
is an antipattern.
So serialization occurs
in this way when
there are many requests.
You're trying to get a lot
out, and get a lot of
information back.
But the problem is that there
are few connections, typically
between two and six.
And a connection is basically
like lanes on a highway.
You can fit only so many cars
horizontally before traffic
starts to pile up behind, like
bumper to bumper traffic.
So this is an example of bumper
to bumper traffic where
one request cannot even be
started until another one has
come back with a response.
And looking closely at this
waterfall, we can see that
these requests overlap each
other three at a time.
And that's not say that this
is in a browser that only
allows three concurrent
connections.
It's actually the case that
there was a very large image
being loaded above these
requests, and that is further
holding up the number
of connections
that could be reused.
So when we look at something
like this, there are a few
best practices that we might
think of about how to solve
this problem.
For images, we might think to,
well, instead of having 12
images, maybe we should combine
them all into one, and
have a sprite.
Another idea is to shard
the domains.
So that connection is per
domain, or that connection
limitation is per domain.
So if we're allowed six
concurrent connections on
example.com, maybe we want
example2.com, or a sub-domain
like img.example.com.
And so in this way, we could, in
theory, split up and get 12
concurrent connections.
Or that's like a 12-lane
highway, as
opposed to a six-lane.
In theory, that should let
us go twice as fast.
But that's not always
the case.
You incur something called
a DNS lookup penalty.
So if you have many new domains
needing to be getting
their IP addresses resolved,
similar to that very first
teal bar we looked at, that has
its own pile up effect.
And it's actually a slow down
of performance gains.
So it's not always a direct win,
just to shard domains.
And I have a note at the bottom,
just to think about
HTTP 2.0, or the speedy
protocol.
And so the note here is that
it's not always a best
practice to shard domains.
Today it might be
a good thing.
But that doesn't mean tomorrow,
when we have the
newer protocols, that it's
still going to work.
And I'll leave it as an example
to the viewer to look
up exactly why it's
called pipelining.
And so the server could handle
many, many requests, like all
12 or so of these at once.
And it could, in theory, handle
this without a stair
step pattern.
So just keep in mind that
although today it is a
problem, it might
not be tomorrow.
And then you're left with the
problem of how do you actually
handle it for the browsers that
don't support this new
protocol today, and try to
get maximal speed up for
tomorrow's browsers.
So this is not necessarily
waterfall, per se.
This is known as the
connection view.
And this is still showing you
the serialization problem.
It's the same pattern, just
in a different view.
And there's a little bit of a
color coding difference here,
and I've noted that using this
line that says CSS JavaScript,
images, and Flash.
And although it's great that we
are loading everything one
after another, we're doing it
as soon as possible, it's
still not ideal.
The connection view is great
because it shows us how we're
reusing our connections.
Reusing a connection is a great
performance win, because
all the way at the left, we
see these six orange bars.
And that is the TCP
connection.
Don't confuse that with this
orange JavaScript line.
It's the same as that first
slide, with the teal and the
orange DNS lookup and the
initial connection.
So we have www1.macys.com
as our domain.
And request four is the first
request to this domain, and so
we have that DNS
lookup penalty.
The subsequent five requests
are able to reuse this DNS
lookup, so that you don't see
that teal lookup on every
other request, or on every
other connection.
But what we do have is this
orange connection opening for
all six of these.
The good news is that it's not
occurring for every subsequent
request, but it is occurring
for every connection.
So it's a very compact type
of pattern, here.
And so we might think that
that's a good thing.
But looking at this in terms
of colors, it's kind of
helpful to see this middle mark,
where the purple images
are back to back with the
orange JavaScript.
And I think that's a good place
to make a cut here, and
say, well, if we were to shard
these domains, and maybe have
www2.macys.com, where we load
the images and the flash, in
theory, we could have
a speed up of 2x.
Again it's not a rule that you
can follow every single time,
that if you split the domains
by a factor of 2, it's going
to be twice as fast.
But in theory, this is an
example of how sharding a
domain could affect this
connection view.
So bringing the two together, we
see connection view and the
waterfall next to each other.
And under one condition, they
are actually almost the same.
There's one connection
for each request, and
that's a bad thing.
And this is because we're not
reusing our connections, or
the connections are closed.
And you'll notice that for each
of these requests, we see
this orange initial connection
being incurred.
And this TCP overhead is
directly affecting the
duration of the request.
So for looking at the first
one here, it takes 177
milliseconds to get all the
information we need.
But it looks like most of that
is being taken up in TCP
connection.
And as we go down, roughly 30
to 50% of these requests are
taking their time in this
connection phase.
And so you might think
of it as a little
sliver on the chart.
It might only take tens of
milliseconds, or hundreds of
milliseconds.
But it does add up, and it turns
out that 50% of the time
taken here is just in this
connection phase.
Again, this red line on the left
is indicating that it is
pushing out this waterfall, and
it's making it harder and
harder to get things done in
a short amount of time.
Luckily, there is an
easy fix here.
On the server side, in your
server configuration file, you
can do something, for example,
like an Apache.
You can enable Keep-Alive.
This is, literally, the line of
code that you need to solve
this problem.
It's a one-liner, under most
general circumstances, and
it's a very quick
and easy win.
There is pretty much no
reason not to do this.
The next pattern is something
that I had to create
artificially just to exacerbate
the problem.
And this is the problem
of network silence.
And this is introducing two more
charts having to do with
the waterfall, and it's the CPU
utilization chart, and the
bandwidth utilization chart.
And network silence can be found
by looking at these two
charts, where bandwidth
utilization is very low, CPU
utilization is very high.
And so we might look at this
and wonder, what could
possibly be going wrong?
And it turns out that it
could be a factor--
multiple factors here.
One of them is that you can
have expensive DOM layouts
being done.
That could be in HTML table,
that's resizing dynamically,
and there's lots of pushing
and pulling going
on inside the table.
And so with that document, with
the browser might do is
hold off on any type of
processing until it knows that
it could display that
table all at once.
And the other thing here is
that you could have some
JavaScript.
As I mentioned earlier, the
browser is single-threaded.
So if you have JavaScript that's
running in a long loop,
that could push out these other
requests that happen.
And so I did come up with this
contrived example here.
And I'll try to pull
this up for you.
Sorry.
So we see here, I'm loading a
page, and nothing happened.
And all of the sudden, we
get this picture back.
And that delay was the
network silence.
We tried to make this page load
as soon as possible, but
we were not able to do it
because of some JavaScript.
So if I could just view
the source here.
Control-Shift-S. There we are.
View page source.
So when I wrote this code, I
was literally going back to
all the worst practices
of web development.
I had a script in the head that
was doing some busy work
for literally five seconds,
pushing values to
an arbitrary array.
And then I used, which made me
cringe, document.write to
write an image out.
And the reason why I had to
use document.write in this
case was because this preloading
done would go and
find the image tag, and try to
preload the image during the
busy While loop up here.
So by using document.write,
that's obscuring the image
that we want to load later.
So this is a very bad pattern,
but I'm using it here just to
show you the effect
on the waterfall.
And so you might see a
big gap in between
one request and another.
And so this is having to do with
your code in particular.
So when you see a big gap like
this, one hint is to look at
the request happening previous
to that gap.
In this case, silence.html is
the only request to occur
before that gap, so we know to
look somewhere in that code.
And as we just did, we saw the
culprits, which was using
document.write and
a long-loading
script in the head.
It's possible that this could
be in the middle of your
waterfall, and it'll be a little
harder to track down,
but it's just something
to keep in mind.
So in summary, we looked at
waterfall slope, and how just
following the left edge of all
these requests could give us a
high level idea of the
performance of our page.
We looked at the individual
request components from DNS
lookup to content download.
We looked at three different
HTTP responses, the redirects,
the conditional GETs,
and the errors.
We looked at the page load
events, and all those colors,
and how that relates the
navigation timing API.
We looked at request
concurrency, and how that can
contribute to the stair step
pattern, and finally, network
utilization.
So we want to do as much with
the network when it's
available as we could.
And so putting this all
together, I put together a few
slides of real waterfalls, and
some really bad things that I
found with them.
This is also introducing the
grades at the top of the
WebPagetest results, A through
F, and X or check mark if
you're using a CDN
effectively.
And in this particular case,
there are 46 requests, and
only five of them
are successful.
And we could see that from this
high level view by all
the red occurring on
the waterfall.
Also, if we were to draw that
waterfall slope line, it would
be horizontal for most of the
time, it turns out 20 seconds,
and all of the sudden it'll
become vertical again.
And this is due to a long time
to first byte in the initial
HTML request.
And that brings up a good point
of when you see a really
long green bar for time to first
byte, that's usually
indicative of a back end
performance problem.
WebPagetest is a front end
performance testing tool, and
it's great at showing you where
you can improve your
front end performance.
But it's not so great
at back end.
And that's on purpose.
It's very focused on
front performance.
So when used in conjunction
with back end performance
testing tools, it's very, very
effective at giving you a full
picture of what's going on.
So although we just have a very
long 20 second green bar,
it's not telling us a lot about
why it's happening.
But it is showing up in our
front end waterfall, so it is
hinting us to look
at the back end.
Also, to note, 30% gzip
savings are possible.
This is why we get a D grade
in our compress transfer.
Next, this is a very, very tall
waterfall, so it's kind
of hard to see what's
going on.
There are 443 requests.
Most of the grades at the
top are kind of decent.
There is an F for time
to first byte, or
our first byte time.
There are 8,000 DOM elements
here, so that's telling me
that there's a lot going
on this page.
We could see some of that low
network utilization because of
expensive DOM layouts,
and things like this.
There's 1.6 megabytes of
JavaScript, which was
surprising to see, because I
don't know what you can even
load that's 1.6 megs
of JavaScript.
Must be uncompressed and
unminified code.
And the funny thing is that,
even from this high level
view, you can still see the
JavaScript from here.
It's almost like the Great Wall
of China from space, even
though it's not true.
So with 443 requests, naturally,
we have 75 unique
domains, which is a lot.
And going back to that point
about DNS lookup, for each of
those 75 unique domains, that's
incurring that DNS
lookup time.
And maybe one of those is having
a bad day, and it takes
a long time to resolve
the IP address.
So always, always try
to minimize the
number of unique domains.
Try to reuse domains as best
as you could, also reusing
your connections.
So before I switch to the next
slide, I'll say that this one
has pretty good grades, but
a really ugly waterfall.
This one has the worst possible
grades, all F's and
an X, and the waterfall
is not as bad.
It's not as big, but there's
still a lot that we
can point out here.
There's two megabytes overall
for the page weight.
It takes 26 seconds
to load the page.
And when we load this page
again, on the repeat view, it
still takes 17 seconds.
I didn't mention repeat views as
much, but this last F grade
cache static content is telling
us how well or how
effective our caching
policies are.
Even with the caching policies
in place, and even with the
browser heuristics to try
to work around some
inefficiencies in your
caching headers, it's
still taking 17 seconds.
So the reason why I put these
next to each other for
comparison is that the grades
that WebPagetest gives you,
all F's and an X, should be an
indicator that there's a lot
that you need to fix here.
But when I go back to the other
waterfall with better
grades, I'm kind of hesitant
to say which one is worse.
I might say that this one is
worse, because there are many
more requests, many more
domains, a much more
complicated DOM, and
so on and so forth.
So take it with a grain of
salt that WebPagetest is
telling you that you might have
done OK, or might have
even done very well.
But there's still room for
improvement, even if
you have all A's.
Another thing to note is that
since these screen shots were
taken, WebPagetest did
have an update.
I think this was in
the past week.
And I did have a chance to find,
it surprisingly did not
take very long, the worst
possible grade, now with six
F's and an X. And the
new grade here is
for agressive jpegs.
I'll let you look into that.
So this is a pretty short
waterfall, maybe
30 requests in total.
But it's getting the worst
possible grade.
So something to keep
in mind is the
waterfall is a great tool.
It's telling you a lot.
It's a little overwhelming at
first, but when you learn to
break things down and look at
requests as individual units,
and break that further down into
all of these different
stages of request, you'll learn
how to interpret the
waterfall, and the reasons why
your website might not be as
fast as you want it.
So that's all that I have.
There's some further reading,
if you choose to do so.
If you're interested in all this
network information, I
highly recommend Ilya Grigorik's
book, "High
Performance Browser Networking."
It's available at
O'Reilly, and there's also
a free preview online.
The WebPagetest documentation
is very thorough.
It's very good.
You can install WebPagetest
locally, on your own machine,
behind your corporate firewall,
and test your
performance from a private
environment.
And the documentation
is invaluable to
help you with that.
Google has a Make the Web Faster
team, and they focus on
not just improving Google
properties,
but the web in general.
And there's many different
initiatives there to improve
the web as a whole.
And also, the "Planet
Performance"
blog aggregator site.
There are many people that are
talking about web performance,
and it's impossible to give
you a link to all of them.
But this aggregator is
a great resource.
Check it every day.
There's tons of new stuff
happening, and I highly
recommend it.
So with that, thank you.
I don't believe that we have any
questions, but if you wish
to reach out to me, here's
my contact information.
I'm on Google+, Twitter.
You can email me here.
My website is jrvis.com.
And a plug for [AUDIO OUT]
I'm giving a hands-on web
performance optimization
workshop, with my co-presenters
Sergey
Chernyshev And Andy Davies.
They're prominent figures in the
web performance world, and
I'm very excited to be
speaking with them.
And this is on Tuesday, June 18,
and it's in Santa Clara.
So with that, thank you for
tuning in, and take care.